not only is art didactic art can be in
many ways persuasive or seductive but
art is also transgressive and the
transgressive function of art is
fundamental in a society that often shiz
away from the difficult topics of
difficult subjects and the difficult
conversations and needs to engage in we
all live in societies that repress and
silenced what's troubling what's naughty
what sort of in some ways I think
threatening but art has this way of
provoking us art has his way of imposing
these silences breaking these silences
imposing these conversations on us and I
think it's absolutely important that we
as society think in ways that we often
don't imagine subjects that we often
sort of shy away from and enter silences
that we're not often encouraged to do so
because in these silences in what's
disavowed is the weights who we really
are as a culture in a society and I
think art has been great for this but as
people you know members of a Civic
Society we also have to push ourselves
into the places they're not entirely
comfortable in silence is where tyranny
and oppression really does its work and
therefore look the conversations that
are often relegated to the margins the
conversations that are considered
impolite those are the conversations
that are much more likely to lead to a
more fair and just society
you